today I'm going to
reprogram my ignition with a new key
from the GM dealership it's going to
take about a half an hour I'm not going
to make you wait a half an hour I'll
just show you the
highlights step one put the key in the
ignition turn the ignition on from
artist like
the from here the vehicle says service
theft deterrent
system now it should remain with that
car lock icon for about 10 minutes then
I'll turn the ignition off and back on
and restart the cycle two more
times so the theft turn just went away
I'm turning off the
ignition and I'm turning it back
on and we've entered the second
round okay the theft tent went away the
second
time turn the ignition
off turn it back
on we should now be in the third and
final phase of the key relearn
process okay the truck just completed
the third cycle and should have now
learned the new key
how about that